hey guys welcome to nerding out the show
or us gamespot nerds get together with
you to talk about the shows that we like
today we're talking about the walking
dead season 7 episode 6 swear ok so this
show revolves around you guys talking to
us we are all nerding out together so
please let us know any concerns any
corrections any theories you have about
the shows that we're talking about we
got a correction last week we messed up
a title sorry about that buddy's fault
what happened just a publishing error
from the last week put it into the
computer wrong you know how computers
are we fixed it though so things lovely
firm sorry so this episode we see Tara
who I forgot about but she's here and
she wakes up on a beach and she's at
beachfront so beachfront is this crazy
place with bunch of crazy ladies
Amazon's Amazon's including the young
ladies so there's this nutty girl Rachel
who's like what 8 and she keeps trying
to kill her she's not she's like a
shooter just like no we have to and
basically so she's just wants to kill
anyone that comes into the community and
so they've gotten rid of all the men
they've killed them in over 10 years old
so Spencer tell us more about beachfront
yeah there is so they're they're part of
I guess you could say the new part of
Megan's wrath so all the men in there
and their group have been killed off
over the age of 10 for starting up
against the Savior's is now they form
their own group and terrorists jump
right in the middle of it it's
interesting to see that the punishment
was different for them than it was for
Rick's crew Rick screwed all their stuff
taken away and two members got killed
whereas these ladies lost all the men so
now it's it's really interesting to see
a different jest on what negan's wrath
is capable of doing and the different
types of punishment I guess he can dish
out to those who a different jest on
Meegan's punishments open ways so yeah
that's I'm gonna jump in on that uh it's
kind of interesting to see what the
results were from the different
punishments and I think that maybe negan
kind of learned that if he's too harsh
with his punishments what happens is
people go rogue they do these weird
Amazonian societies where they
everyone that gets near them and he
doesn't get half of their stuff and then
half their stuff and then half their
stuff and half their stuff which is
interesting i think it's great too
because it allows us to see a different
side of the whole situation and maybe
also is the idea that you know maybe
nians learning to kind of self control
himself because this was pretty bloody
for him to kill all those people like
that and then he loses a crew he loses a
whole group he's like oh maybe I need to
tone it down a bit all right I'll just
knock off to people and we'll see how it
goes from there i'm gonna knock off two
guys blocks yeah just two guys this time
too just to Greg does this plot seem
familiar to you at all um well yeah I
was going to that time for the opening
shot was very lost II just wondering
that up very off the lad oh right away
credible when they had her on the beach
and the whole thing and drags her off
that was completely by yes but also like
a little bit of TNG really just so just
a tiny we touch that nerds at home what
T&G is in case they're not into it you
nerd the next generation Star Trek he's
talking about Star Trek yes there's a
few episodes that they kind of like
heart awful but one of them was a Clues
which is just pretty much the crew gets
the memory white they find an alien race
that doesn't want anybody to find them
so they have the micro memory or killed
him uh interesting unfortunately data is
the one that uh kind of screws that
whole thing up for them so that's I got
that a second they're like hey we either
when we find somebody gotta kill him on
the spot oh thanks wait TNG alright so
we have these four forces we've got
beachfront Alexandria hilltop the
kingdom are they going to clash or than
you team up what do you thinks gonna
happen buddy um I think it at this point
they have alexandria has a foothold in
all three of the other colonies which is
cool Tara doesn't really have a foothold
as much as she has a you know slightly
awkward interaction or tried to kill her
a couple of times I think it's fine
though because they know we're now so
Maggie is kind of primed to take over a
hilltop and I think Carol kind of has an
inn in the kingdom although the kingdom
is bonkers anyway I think that all they
need to do is say like we have a quest
will you son
zekiel will be like great let's do it i
have a tiger I'm insane so I think that
that everything is going to kind of come
together there's going to be like a you
know a parlay or a meeting everyone
being like hey do you hate Megan do you
hate negan how about you cool he killed
my friends on the bat oh you too great
what's been more people die from their
cruise right right rocks fall everyone
does but i think that's that's
definitely going to be the course of
this obviously we all see how the
interactions are gonna happen yeah so
what do we see happening next besides
this Spencer uh so recently the actor
Chandler Riggs who plays Carl on the
show recently it's coming to light both
thanks to him and to his mother going on
Twitter that his contract is seven-year
contract you can the own tweet ax is 70
or contracts up and so this has kind of
led to a lot of people speculating that
he may be heading out of the show
because he wants to pursue a career in
college which is great but it kind of
makes it a little bit of an idea then
I'm kind of hoping that he actually does
bite the dust now granted crawl plays a
big part in the comics specially
canoeing on where the show is at right
now but I think that would be pretty
damn sweet that if he did bite the dust
I'd be the final push for Rick to kind
of snap out of it yeah hey man guess
what you're not safe you gotta we gotta
do something about this guy right now I
also improbably don't you do it the
first or the billionth person on the
internet to say I do not like this actor
do not like his long hair I think that
the only thing that they tied him to the
they tied him to the character in the
comic book by putting a hat on him the
guys like six foot eight like he's not a
little kid me more least are in the Hat
were my dad's hat I'm still wearing my
hat and not getting a haircut yes how
you know it's Carl you have to know
somehow yeah yeah well he doesn't have
an eye which is also yeah so it's gonna
be interesting to see if indeed he does
leave the show and if he does decide to
leave the show if they do get rid of him
that's gonna be a big gap in the comics
and going further onto the show so would
they replace him with someone else who
knows so make any predictions gonna have
Daryl take over that whole role for Carl
give him a hat give him the head and
Harry yes he already has a hair
they could also eat gehrels out there
still yeah what's happened girl so
you're gonna have to deal with that and
that could be the thing with he said for
Carl kill a Carl Erskine you got me in
with Darryl there anything to have him
maybe that can't interaction they had in
the comic book oh yeah that weird lon
yeah I think they could have that go on
now where they have those too he takes
over Carl's like a little bit across
three lanes not all of it creepy little
interaction with you again where they
yeah so negan gets put in jail in
alexandria in the comic book and Carl
goes and talks to them and they have
this weird relationship and if we kill
Carl which I hope would kill cool that's
such a cool theory that Daryl's there
would be the one to take over for that
if they have to have that weird
interaction I feel like they're also
winging the Darryl carrot around like
somebody's gonna die is it gonna be it
could be I know I feel like to kill
Daryl off at this point it's probably
not gonna happen I think these low for a
long we're only a couple episodes to the
mid-season finale so I feel like someone
of significance will die but not someone
super duper important so I don't think
its Darryl's time it though that would
be freaking crazy but I think it's
probably Carl yeah yeah I'm sad at the
very least a haircut yeah at the very
least that's his punishment it descended
them crying as his hair is being
shopping oh the next episode is called
sing me a song and we want to get you
involved on the conversation so please
please please comment below tell us if
we mess anything up tell us if buddy
said something weird tell us what you
think is going to happen or if someone's
going to die in the mid-season finale
what do you predict by the way if anyone
sings us a song about what they think is
going to happen in sing us a song will
post the whole thing you'll get it
gamespot will go behind you sing us a
song about it yeah send it to us on
twitter use the hashtag GS nerding out
and we will run those videos if you sing
us a song about the walking dead and if
no one does then one of us is gonna sing
a song holy SH and you don't want that
so please don't want and for all things
rooting out stick with gamespot universe
you